brothers and sisters helped me on this
new project to sponsor 50 orphans
brothers and sisters in charlotte it's
600 pounds a year but i wanted every one
of you guys to get involved by giving
even if it's one pound
please get involved now each other and
help us sponsor 50 offense for an entire
year
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salam 10 for 10 of them so guys we're
doing a social experiment
but we came across a group of sisters uh
and
our experiment today is about atheists
but we've got fears
you all believe in god right yeah so we
all believe in god so we have that in
common
but we came across uh sister what's your
kiara so name kiara was just walking
past um she noticed myself and she
wanted to
talk and you are you uh christian yeah
i'm a catholic
okay you said you're interested in islam
what what's
what made you interested in islam and
like where are you like are you on the
verge of accepting
are you still like double-minded um i'm
still trying to educate myself
on it and like um find more information
about it but
i think i am very close to converting i
just need to read more
and see what like you said something
about march you said something what was
that
i went to the yemen um protest um last
year
and everyone was praying and everyone
was like very welcoming to me even
though i didn't
i wasn't able to say the prayers and i
just saw how great the community was and
i don't know i just haven't always felt
like i've had a place in
you know yeah you know with like islam
like how how would your family feel
about that like if he was
because you know me when i first came to
islam like my dad kicked me out the
house
because there was a hostile and that's
because of certain things that they've
seen in the media
so like how would you how would your
family take that do you have muslims in
your family because i know eritrea is
like
yeah like half of my family are muslim
oh really yeah and like um we have very
close family friends who are muslim
but they are very strong catholics so i
don't think they would want me to
convert but
if it's the truth like to me it was like
if i know it's the truth i don't know if
the entire globe is against me do you
guys have to be real to myself
because i can't look in the mirror and
be like i'm fake because a group of
people don't like me
so i admire that like do you understand
the concept of islam like the god
like do you or should i tell you about
that you can tell me okay you know what
it is like with us
like this one we're really close to
christians like god almighty tells us
that we can marry christians we can eat
from their food
etc so we have that connection uh
because that's what we call them the
people of the book
and we're very close even though people
make it seem like you know we don't like
each other i don't think that's the case
you know because we believe in
uh jesus you know even though we believe
him to be a prophet but
all all in islam i'm not going to keep
you guys wrong i'm sorry i'm going to be
i'll be two minutes yeah
the the what we believe in is like the
pure monetism of god
so we don't believe man god is a man or
he's a human being
or he was born or he died you know we
believe in the true essence the
monotheism of god
which is jesus because like um which
jesus said that for example
um he would when he went to the mountain
of gethsemane he
he he went in a praying position and
prayed so we say if he was god
who was he praying to so he always
refers to the father jesus always says
my father is greater than i
uh and my father is he always says good
things about him even one of the
disciples that came to him and said
oh good master what must i do to get
eternal life he said why do you call me
good there is only one good and that's
good
to us that's why we say jesus was a
muslim in that sense because he always
refers to god
so the basic thing that we call like
people in general too
is that god is unlike his creation
anything that you think of in your mind
cannot be good because anything that you
think in your mind has a beginning and
an end
you know so that's why we just tell
people that for example our christian
brothers and sisters in humanity
that to worship god alone and that's and
one of the biggest
sins is to associate partners so for
example you guys all agree like your
parents brought you up to this age right
now imagine if you grew up and you
turned around to your mom or dad and
said
you've done nothing for me i'm gonna go
and thank ali how would they feel
they wouldn't like it right yeah they
wouldn't they wouldn't like no
yeah so the thing is what we're saying
is that to show gratitude to your mom
and dad
is fundamental it's very important in
islam what about the one that gave you
your mom and dad
so that's the reason why in islam we
believe that god almighty deserves all
our
submission and obedience if i go and
start thanking a statue like there's a
statue there if i go and say oh thank
you statue
god tell this in the quran that's that
you can't harm you or benefit you it's a
statue
you know so in islam in in in a nutshell
i'll let you go i don't want to hurt you
guys
in a nutshell is that to worship god
alone and have that connection with him
and if you have any questions you can
ask uh it's totally up to you
but read the quran um i'm in sp you know
hyde park yeah i'm there every sunday
yeah if there's any questions you want
to ask you can or i'll come down there
no problem we're there thank you very
much
i'm so sorry i try to keep it as